what's up guys it's mary and XCOM and
i'm here to tell you about all the video
games coming out this week if you are
familiar with the turn-based tactical
alien killin game you'll be happy to
know that all the things you loved about
XCOM unknown are still there like
character customization where you can
get to name and style your characters
after the people you love so you can
watch them rise through the ranks or die
like dogs but now after you make
decisions the scenes that play out are
more immersive and better looking than
ever before check out our beloved
producers like Danny O'Dwyer and yours
truly armored up and ready for war
you're gonna want to give this one a go
and the game is out on the 5th also this
week we get the great detective Pikachu
on 3ds Pikachu who solves cases
alongside his companion Tim Goodman but
what makes this one a little weird is
Pikachu talks and he behaves like a
human he's arguing contemplating and
he's even sweet-talking the ladies it's
a little out there this comes out on the
third also this week North America and
Europe get gravity rush known in Japan
as gravity days it was previously
released on Vita but the remastered
version looks nicer and it comes with
all that downloadable content you can
change the direction of gravity to walk
up walls and upside down on ceilings and
kick some butt plus your name is Kat and
you have a cat so if that doesn't seal
the deal I don't know what will that's
out on the second this week you can pop
some pills and stay up all night play
American Truck Simulator there will be
more than 100 cities in the game and
will feature California and Nevada on
the initial release looks like Arizona
will be released as a free update
shortly after you get to live the life
wearing trucker hats and listening
country music and dodging lot lizards
which I recently learned is the term for
scrubby prostitutes that prey on
truckers well I guess you can just live
the life how you want it on the second
Mojang is gifting PC and Xbox users with
cobalt this week where you're a cute
robot with a passion for 2d battles
packed with extreme slo-mo and combat
roles his game has been in the works for
a while you might have already played it
but the final version offers
user-generated content a complete main
adventure mode and same computer
multiplayer you can grab it on the
second we're also getting the fifth game
in the digimon story series digimon
story cyber sleuth players get a device
called a digimon capture from a
mysterious stranger in a chat room come
on it's 2016 we do not accept links from
a serious chat strangers but basically
you use this tinder Digimon app to help
a detective solve cyber crimes from
hackers cyber sleuth is out on the
second also finally coming to North
America and Europe is mega dimension
neptunia 7 the game features a new
battle system with a different combo
structure to previous games in the
series the gameplay places a strong
emphasis on the position of your
characters and each goddess character
has a next form which gives you an
additional transformation on top of
their existing goddess transformations
the forum's change your combat style and
personality that's out on the second
finally we get not a hero where you kill
a bunch of bad guys to help a purple
rabbit bunny Lord who's traveled back in
time from 2048 he wants to be elected as
mayor's we can save the world from total
destruction and alien invasion
presumably he shows the people why he
should be elected by setting up
freelance anti-heroes that's you to
clean up crime in the city under his
name kill kill kill save save save and
this action-packed blood splattering
side-scrolling murder fest and it
releases on the second and that's it for
this week I'm going back into the fray
to kick some alien butt and XCOM 2 won't
you join me see you next week
you